hey
hello hi everybody i'm mary i'm here
with eric my good buddy what up i think
we're gonna play some stupid time force
today hopefully yeah i'm pretty excited
um
i've never never played it seen a lot
about it july she just played for like
two i did play it for a minute i did
play uh i learned a few things i learned
how to jump
uh and then i learned how to
die
yep i went into helping options and i
learned how to play
so
you start with 60 seconds on the clock
and you have to make it to the end of
the level before time runs out so that's
about as much now we're about at the
same
speed here we're all up to date so
let's just get into it let's all right
so just so you guys know and to make
ourselves look a little bit better let's
be kind here this is caro's like account
and her game and for whatever reason i
don't know if super hardcore is like the
level you get after you beat the game
yeah but that's what we're playing on
and i've never played it and i've played
about five minutes so this is gonna be
good
we're just gonna play super hardcore
mode let's do it where do you want to go
what time period i don't know
um does anyone in the chat have any idea
where you guys want to go in time i mean
obviously we want to party like it's
1999. um
but you can also go back to the
dinosaurs
um guys garage i believe this is
to wield weapons
was that that was a lizard doing some
graffiti
pinball machines
yeah look at that look at that sweet
base they got
all those bunk beds the guys shining his
gun
kind of
i think that's a biz like a bazooka or a
rocket launcher yeah yeah
it looks pretty badass
um so
we got a
yeah we got a 19.99 and we also have a
one million bc that's a tough call eric
i don't know you're the tiebreaker let's
go dinosaurs all right you know we're
gonna go with the dinosaurs because i
always party like it's 19.99
that is true
i learned that when i was a weep a child
although i really feel like crocodiles
look like dinosaurs a little bit
asteroid came down
from heaven
and sucker punched those lizards right
in their faces oh man look at that
triceratops playing basketball that was
that's what happens when you smash a
butterfly in the past
we don't have dinosaurs playing b-ball
with us
unfortunate
it's interesting that with all this
technology and fighting force and i
assume they're very smart
that they are changing things in the
past to
have dinosaurs play basketball i also
heard they do like really stupid things
that they can have like
certain types of food and like it's
awesome like hamburgers and stuff like
that like they're weird
weird choices oh
i killed those yeah we killed those
little
up-and-coming dinos i'll never play
basketball
i just get there and i think of a crazy
plan yeah look at how many medals that
guy has
he had two eye patches commander
rapidski
right i'm guessing cdr's commander
like
got all those medals and no
eyes you're gonna start as
i don't know i think rambo is the
easiest or uh sorry that's not his name
but uh what does he look like that guy
just okay jean ramboys jean rambo ramboy
you need to
work on your front my front side your
francia all right so i know how to jump
okay this appears to be that's shoot and
you can charge that one you can charge
that one up shoot it because the contra
s oh that's pretty cool yep
you can also slow time also and i
believe i can time out yeah
but i want to be me again so now i have
two of me so that's kind of like the
funky thing that you can do in this
i would say don't take your time mary
you got 40 seconds
i forgot about the time in the time
force game
so we will gradually pick up clocks
which will get away
all right i died oh man baby dino's got
you so i'm gonna go backwards in time
you probably want to go a little bit
further so you can save your buddy or
save your lap your previous self
good work saved him nice so i i got a
power up i believe from saving his life
from going back in time and saving my
own friend
oh plant eater
oh look at that bounce shot yeah that's
interesting
oh so those
gold bees oh you and your bees are so
good giant there's frogs too
eat it frog
bees my arch nemesis your arch nemesis
everybody's got one mine just happens to
be bees so where are you going oh
good work
oh god everything freaking kills i think
you want to go to the right
you want to go to the right you got 15
seconds oh right you gotta hustle i
forgot about the time
this isn't your normal platformer
oh it's okay i would rewind all the way
back we mean before i made my horrible
mistake in terms of going taking way too
much time yep
that seems like a reasonable i think if
you hold left stick it will go faster
advanced technique right there
um
melanie gibson appears
short range shotgun that's a shotgun oh
i thought it was a boomerang yeah there
is a guy with a boomerang though uh i
think it's a guy it's a small i don't
even know what it is to be honest i'm a
shotgun lady
way to pull it back there bringing in
the reins
i need that i assume yes you do it's
clock
but how much clock did you lose getting
it oh no i'm in trouble it's okay you
can you can rewind all right i forgot
about sweet rewind
makes up for mistakes
you gotta make gotta make those jumps
mary no i wanna be me
oh uh i didn't think this let's pretend
like it didn't happen just pretend like
that there you go
so of course if you wait i died so now i
have to choose someone else is that the
way it works uh you were supposed to be
able to pick yourself again i think if
you save her
she should become available again there
you go and then i got my own time yep
sorry oh
you guys so it just keeps releasing bees
it is
it is a nest
if you guys have any questions we'll try
to answer them
to the best of our knowledge yep
which is not very knowledgeable
my knowledge is
you're running out of characters you're
going to like have to like start playing
the melee characters which is kind of
rough but there we go
yeah kill those hornets i'm assuming
those are i think there's a cooldown you
got 10 seconds i can't
there's no way i'm gonna beat it in time
there's a clock thing up there though
so if you get past this part
uh we're on xbox one
uh
which dinosaur are you talking about
sock to me
you got slow-mo time yeah
i really needed it oh these are hanging
vines yeah
get to that clock i need it so badly 18
seconds
oh god i got raptored
do you think i could save his life i
think so
running out of i don't know
zack asaurus i don't know any of these
people okay so those three are melee
he's got a really strong punch like that
it's commander repeat skis
can i punch this b yeah can also fall
into
just rewind it you know didn't happen
make it like it didn't happen
oh man running out of characters here oh
is that like mace windu look alike
got slashed
nice
good work
oh
i don't know what that is but i want it
what is this like hmm
i didn't anticipate
nato
oh you're the skateboarding lizard oh it
came from behind though i'm not gonna
make it right what do you do when you
run out of characters
well i didn't have that problem earlier
i was able to replay the guys that i had
oh
lordy
it's not looking so hot
maybe the uh
all right let's let's start over from
the safe confines
it's all up to boomerangs that's all i
have
get that clock oh god i need that oh you
can get the dinosaur guy back
yeah zackasaurus after all that death
i survived oh
my god barney it's barney
it's barney
that didn't go so well did not
oh man this this is rough guys
trust me it's rough
we can do it
oh do they have like um
what are those hats called
you think it's definitely not fedora but
it's one of those kind of uh i just
picked one at random oh why okay
you got the commander lopitsky
he's got the universe
well you gotta you gotta kind of weigh
when you have time to charge and when
you don't you need to
know your
yeah and you know what i need to what
lu don jan
oh you're going with bazookas
save them yeah nice
everyone
die
good you're doing way better than last
time oh you just
i did my other
did my other dude die uh i think you
saved him so it's okay but you just lost
your power up
i think i'm gonna go with more speed
yeah agility on this run
i think what i've learned is oh god can
i yeah yeah it's about getting there
i thought i could jump on his head no i
feel like i think the shield person you
can jump on heads or at least one shoe
shielders then yeah when she was powered
up she could jump on heads i think
i'll save him
he's everywhere so many bees
i might be able to save her yeah there
was that tip that told you to kill
everything and i feel like you don't
want to kill everything
man that guy got
away big the big hand a big fist
oh
man i wanna i wanna jump on top of
people so bad got that mario in you
oh he's that lightsaber
yeah
all right we're doing way better we
never
than last time we're we're like 20
seconds ahead it's like most of these
kills or surprise kills where a dinosaur
a dinosaur kind of just came out of
nowhere comes oh
did you say that i don't know did you oh
you did
good work
so the key is if you're in trouble just
rewind it as fast as possible
like right now
look it didn't happen
what just happened i don't know i think
i killed him oh no
you can save him up too late it's okay
get zackasaurus out oh hey he can jump
on people because he's got skateboard
does that make sense that does make
sense achievement unlocked
head banger
all right so i don't have the hair a
giant dinosaur does come out
oh man
assume i have to kill him so he's got
sparklies on his back what does that
mean
oh nice oh
what is that
what is that that is some that is some
dinosaur [ __ ] right there i'm just gonna
keep my distance
no
wait it was actually a sound plan it was
a sound point again
little did we know there was a dinosaur
bigger than that dinosaur it was a
dinosaur oh there you go the zackasaurus
took care of it i think he's got a oh my
goodness it's a dinobot that doesn't
seem like any dinosaur i've ever read
about
i don't know i don't know man i'm
running out of people again maybe you
can shield it back at him did you use
shield
shieldy blockerson
yeah
oh does it just oh what he's gonna have
guys it's me
he's kind of rolling for a while he's
just got a robot guy chilling in his
mouth
okay this plan was not so great okay all
right here's my thought though i'll use
him as a shield yeah
and then and then hope to kill him in
seven seconds kill him in seven seconds
listen sounds good where's your plan i'm
trying to think of one too but our plans
aligned
and they ended up being the same thing
also you're low on characters so you
have a melee guy and the guy that can
throw boomerangs
we're gonna go with boomerang all right
here you go there you go
you didn't believe in the blocker so it
did not
i don't know how oh you can use the
unibeam
charge up and use the beam
okay that did absolutely nothing oh you
know what i bet you have to kill the guy
inside
you're probably right let's try again
because that dinosaur is not taking any
damage
that wasn't me was it i needed that guy
to live
oh my goodness i needed that guy how do
you
my commission failed we got there though
did i i think third time's a charm
they're telling me oh my god you're
gonna take over after this one i'm not
good at it all right the pass i don't
know only the future only in the future
or 1999
where it was a great year
i'm only good at partying in 1999.
okay i believe in you mary
love those grenades
go gross
what that's what they're doing
i think you can angle it down yeah there
you go
oh it bounces they do bouncy
oh i feel like i'm learning about the
bonuses of these characters far too late
hey man trial and error that's how it
goes sometimes
peace
oh yeah
i think you go far back enough you just
have to get there and save him or like
kill the you gotta get there first
and kill the
you pour it they jump into it and then
save them
yeah now we're getting it where you're
getting all right
way to get through there it's okay it's
okay you got the one-ups oh
sticky situation there's a lot of stuff
a lot of stuff going on this is that
super hardcore mode
you're gonna use
shotgun lady
wait you didn't rewind far enough i
gotta i gotta plan this way better
this is what happened last time
saber
get them both oh
oh
almost you save one of them
the bees nice i'm like getting murdered
your best friend you can save them all i
think if you go back far enough really i
think you can save them all
like
okay that was kind of much but too far a
little too far like right
around here i think
maybe even right after
just charge that charges his s
or that works too
i'm the worst at this game i don't think
anyone
i am pretty sure i did a worse job just
now
nice boomerangs boomerang clearly
effective moderately effective it's like
the leaf shield the mega man leaf shield
too strong
oh you saved somebody because you're
you're glowing good
oh how did he okay i was going to say if
he went through that that's a hot pile
of garbage
i got it i gotta get it i got it just
time out it
i got it i gotta go did you save her
before the second death
go from there yeah you did okay
nice good work start spinning spinning
the boomerangs
wait no that's not what i wanted um
that's the other one
it's okay you're thinking about it
nice i'm out of boomerangs no no oh is
that what that is you can't use anymore
did you save her
yes okay
nice
good work
pretty confused
it's okay it's okay it doesn't have to
make sense i mean i'm sure if we're
tactically better at this game it would
make sense but
i'll kill those guys
no
they got zakasaurus
i don't think that guy does anything so
you can arrange them you can swappy
there's the real deal
grimlock
grimlock on crack because he has he's
blockers in right oh you need a round oh
it's a range i need like a little bit
longer maybe
yeah you need a sniper did you kill is
she dead though she died no no she's
alive she's alive she's alive
sniper is the one with the
the long rifle yeah ally
you're at the bottom you're at the
bottom don't get confused
i got confused so
i don't know how you avoid this fire
though okay were you actually hurting
them there i don't know it doesn't look
like it does it yeah but
there's nothing that's representing like
you're doing this so bad i needed that
gun
you need to save her can you save her
with blocky blockers blocky
mcblockersons
yeah just keep that up
nice i think you saved her
the problem now is you only have nine
seconds
i
don't know if i need more than that
i don't know rewind how to kill him i
don't either actually
oh there's a health bar on the right i
didn't even notice that so
that is hurting him actually i'm out of
time all right so that was hurting him
every time you shot him even though it
doesn't look like you're doing damage
can i have her twice
yeah yeah you can have her as long as
you saved her but you need way more
damage like way more damage like before
blocky but then you don't have another
there you go
go ham
yeah do the shield dude first do this
shield yeah do the shield for well it's
too late for that now
how far back in time shall we go uh i
think off
all the way can't we add people to it
because that's the whole point of this
right is that
them yeah if you keep saving them they
do
they're supposed to clone like what you
did previously and then when you save
them they just appear right so there she
is again so now i'm doing double damage
and i assume yes you can just keep doing
that oh so close okay so if i just do it
again should i have three of them
yes how is this
you just need more damage there you go
just keep doing that
now get a fifth get a fifth one
four wasn't enough so we need five i am
gonna beat this dinosaur
look at that yeah okay we need one more
six we need
we need more power
okay we need seven
apparently we need seven
perhaps eight perhaps eight
i'm sorry i'm bad at math
i'm bad at math we need eight
yeah
take that he's like the x on his eye
okay take that oh man present time i
wouldn't even thought about that i
didn't know it kept making that many
clones is it just like the millisecond
after or something i guess i guess as
long as they don't die i can just keep
summoning them and then have like a
hundred of me and make my own so we
could have kept going there
yeah force field of it yeah that's all
of them we comboed one person so is this
my run now i can like watch yeah you can
watch it all the horrible decisions that
i've made what are the great decisions
this is where i learned i could lob
grenades downward yep yep all right i
think we've seen enough of that horrible
play but i did do it you did it
i'm glad i made it i'm glad i made it
life coaches are making good progress
ah
this game is uh not multiplayer right i
just think it's just like single player
single player yeah but you have multiple
characters sounds like we're having fun
together yeah so
my god
yeah that wasn't cheating that was just
game design and we figured it out a
little later peter who called me a
cheater
uh
dj giga called us cheaters nope
i think we're the cheater i think
we uh played the game the way it was
intended
is this only for xbox i believe it's
only 360 and xbox one i'm this is this
blue soldier this blue soldier man it's
too strong
there's a spike oh there's a spike there
well i've gone through about eight of my
dudes okay so i feel really confident
that um the last thirty percent of them
will should actually start this whole
thing over you can just go from the
select screen and start over
that would be truly cheating though is
it no i mean like i think you can save
them all i think you can save them all
this way
if you get over there fast enough
what are those pixel art guys flying
across the screen
go save them go save them all how do i
save them all just jump into them
there you go i think you saved everyone
but one of them which is pretty good
don't jump into that spike okay
good good call
oh you slowed time you're in matrix mode
do it
let's look at dinosaurs why is that a
sparkly dinosaur i assume that means
some kind of like fossil
it's got a reward for you
oh oh my god they're making out yeah
they're totally tonguing each other that
was probably inappropriate to say
okay i said it
say tonguing that's what was happening
look
oh it's okay you got that double hp
wait well that one did it yeah
it's all right you can see i wasted all
going that way because you don't know
there's a clock there though you got
time over there will that guy go get it
i guess technically yeah i guess you
yeah if you if you traverse back far
enough yeah
oh that short range sawed off shotgun
nice
oh
you could have saved them too now you
got to save both of them
believe in her she's going to do it
just save them both
oh i don't think i saved her i think you
can still save him uh i can't save
anyone apparently
maybe i can save both of them if i do
this correctly yeah
so picking the right person for the job
i think that's why there's that many
characters right so you can uh oh so
close we killed each other okay now you
can save all of them because you took
out the guy that took out everyone so
what do i do then
you just let them play let it play out
just kidding well close enough you saved
three of them save rambo oh my god
oh what am i supposed to do save the guy
below
and does cleo really only have that many
i don't understand he's almost dead
does that kill me
yeah because you you jumped into him i
think
better go
melanie gibson
yeah there you go
savor oh yeah
i forgot about saving
oh that could have been dangerous though
actually
yeah it's okay i would be doing worse
that's why i'm having you play oh man
his punch absorbs the bullets
okay
oh i thought i could
do something
jump on his head
oh my god
i can do this
yeah i haven't heard anything about a pc
release
10 seconds
get more time
saber dinos yeah
oh you can reflect it yeah swing him
back oh
think i can save him
possibly
punch those bullets
oh
that's unfortunate what just occurred
there
also five seconds how am i do it
supposed to possibly be this
uh i think part of it is just learning
the map
to be honest because you know once you
figured out the other map you were able
to get through it
go to the right
just screw the yellow diamonds we're not
at the level of doing cheap we're not at
the level to finish
we can make it
we can make it just keep getting clocks
at the last minute oh that's not a good
look
so will he get the clock if i pick
someone else i think so yes
and you can save them too
yep oh now
yeah yeah
what am i doing
yes we are playing on xbox one that is
mary i'm eric you guys are watching a
now playing of super time force
oh zak saurus
i don't know what i'm doing it's okay am
i supposed to just kill everything you
just gotta be a cool dude
that's what zack source or a cool dino i
assume i'm just supposed to kill as many
things
oh no i [ __ ] died
that happens
oh commander repeats keys
strong hand
i don't know where you're supposed to go
after that we should find out at least
where you're supposed to go that's a
really good thing to say
maybe i'm just supposed to kill it oh is
it like one of those yeah
like maybe this is the final yeah a
little area you just got it's uh like a
horde mode kind of thing scenario oh no
i died i think i'm in trouble
just keep making more of those no i died
no no
it's up to
what was his name the france the french
guy's name
john ramboi
our french is slowly either getting
worse or better
that's the secret to french is that you
ever never actually know
okay that was better and then that the
the arrow is telling you to go right
after though oh
i immediately died
it appears that way okay guys we failed
the mission but
don't worry we're going to come back in
just a few
less than a minute and we're going to
beat it because mary's going to get
better i am going to get better in time
and we're back and mary
is in full focus mode i am in the zone
y'all
i think she she's got it down now we're
going to play it a little safer
uh hopefully oh man oh they're wicked
yeah i have no idea
actually
how did he how did he bite you there
it's time for blocky blockerson oh yeah
to block teeth to block the teeth you
got to get up
oh you stopped him from charging you
though that's kind of cool
can you step on him i think he can yep
oh hey did you see that when you charged
the sniper that you had saved charge
that's the combo effect
go blocky i think with her you have to
jump on people that's the only way she
can kill
blocky
useless
piles it's not her fault okay she only
has a shield you can't ask her for more
there you go
oh
it's okay i
i'm poking fun but i wouldn't be doing
any better so
all right i'm gonna save some people
right here do it
save me blockerson
oh
ah too late it's all right
nope
i like how he loses his sunglasses
i keep going back in time i can save
both of them i think okay yeah you
definitely can save
nope i can't
i just oh
that's all i'm hearing
hello jess
i can't save anyone you can save
everyone you have to believe it is
unclear you have to believe that you're
gonna save everyone not like that though
all right i think that person kills him
so then i should save a few people
man you got the whole roster in that one
spot
hi
so oh
i punched him with my fist
i'm confident i heard i heard you press
the button but it definitely didn't come
out when you
wanted it to i'm losing a lot of people
in this sequence
i'm a little worried
no
no
i like these
death noises though how far back should
i even go
how far back
i don't know i almost feel like you
should just it's a lost cause and you
might have to just like oh no okay save
them both
all of them oh look at this combo meter
crap that you got going on oh they all
died
oh i didn't
do a very good job
this guy on the corner is absolutely the
worst the worst trying to think of how
you would kill him the easiest
and the rage is building if there was
like a rage meter like right here
i'm raging
i'm out of people and i don't know how
to save anyone and all i have is blocky
blockers you gotta do a super jump and
pray
there you go you hold down the shield
all right let's let's straight let's
swap
i'll try to save you from here i can't
oh that was blocky block or sim
i if i was pressures on a general in a
war i would just keep throwing
more people at the enemy i think we
would just have aerial strikes and call
it a day i wouldn't even send my people
in
it's kind of it's kind of dark
what ariel
aerial assault
that's a way better job than what i've
been doing
just gotta
have the right tools
contra you mean bullets
cause i had those i had all the tools
you're talking about
slow and steady wins the race
except not in this game sometimes you
don't have any
except not in this game how do you get
up there
no okay all right that's fine get up
there uh let's see
so he's gonna eventually kill him right
okay
so who can uh maybe maybe the grenade
jeff leopard if you can lob it up there
oh you
come on
oh john
it's so familiar this scene
is it i feel like i've traveled back in
time
is this like you can do this
game is maybe the epitome of
deja vu
come on go oh my
oh and then there's so stupid this is
there's a glitch in the matrix all right
at this game thanks thanks first first
game first game i got crap talked
already no i was no better
so he'll kill those people he doesn't
die there oh yeah but i didn't grab that
coin did i
going downhill
it's going what started off really well
it's getting exponentially worse but
that's the thing about time is you can
just go back to a time
when you weren't [ __ ] at the game
exactly
because you were really good until like
here
why can't i save him
there you go i'm like too distracted
into trying to save these people that
like you gotta save those guys hurry
save them
save them save them save them nice
now that guy will be maybe
that guy's super dead
we're playing super time force and that
guy
super duper was it to the left what's it
to the world
something
don't hit that spike
oh
stupid kickback on that shotgun you
might be able to save him just kill him
before that guy does
okay
what do we got
i need that um
yeah i think i would do it go go go go
hurry just one shot him
did you save him he said i don't know
there you go good job
thanks
words of encouragement
not what i was offering you apparently
no
oh
so many things kill you
there's just a lot of bad decisions the
way they balance out the fact that you
can go back in time the fact that you
can choose like eight people and you can
have this giant team
is that everything
murders you
will you gonna get the dyno
you really could use um blocky blockers
in there like that was like the optimal
time
use the force i am
you have 15 seconds
oh i threw the no no this is not the
time to throw the lightsaber come back
you threw it in slow motion
come back to me you can witness your bad
decision in slow motion yeah okay fine
that's that's fair enough that's so
good let's watch it yeah it took so long
to learn that was a poor choice
punch those dinos in the
face oh yeah there you go oh that was
good
all right so you need to go you only
have 11 seconds you need time ah fine go
backwards go back in time go back so go
back in time because that
you're eventually killing right okay and
then you can be and you can be him again
beam again okay and then that guy will
kill him and you keep going
i just can't do you know what i mean
yeah yeah i just gotta let that guy kill
him and die like that
nobody saw that okay nobody
i know
so i get too caught up in going uh go
but he killed him he will kill him jump
over him or something
crap
i want to rewind i'll go nope yeah go go
go go go no no we we we definitely need
to rewind there i mean you did a bad job
i know that's why we're also past it
i know but it took me way too long to
kill
nice now go
now we need to switch again
and what
so like someone oh none of my gun guys
are alive
we're in trouble you are in trouble
big chubs
chomp those dinosaurs okay so wait no go
back in time okay that guy will get
everybody on the bottom row
and then you worry about the top row see
i'm saying yeah okay all right we're
getting real
now get it get the other top row go back
in time
yeah go back
well you're i know i died no
save him
you have to save him
i can't save him did not save him
that was that my last guy
no it'll say it'll say that you're okay
the game no longer is working
get my lease shield going
did you die
perhaps
i got don't worry i got shield
mcblockerson
the best character we're down to shieldy
blockerson
oh it got my toe you didn't shield i
shielded the wrong side they're they're
pinching me oh taking the controller
back in one attempt i thought i did
pretty well there
we're going to 1999. this is pretty much
both of our first times playing wow
whose baby is that oh you're going to
1999. i am going
to save this baby cleopatra jr
nice babies are so boring it's just like
a big sack of meat
that just poops
a pooping sack of meat
i will say though like uh we're starting
you're starting to see the intricacies
of this game and kind of
the strategy more complicated than it
appears i think at first glance i
thought it was like a shmup that had
some platforming in it um
that whole ability to go back in time
constantly have eight of the same person
is huge
um so it sounds like
by the time you get to like the fourth
round
that's supposed to be like mad max or
something it looks exactly like mad max
but we murdered him so now those movies
were never made it's okay
that video game ever get made i heard
they're making a mad max video game
yeah wasn't it e3 last year it was like
a few years ago and i was like remember
getting pumped for it and then i just
never saw anything there was like a cg
trailer right in the car
yeah yeah yeah yeah i thought that might
have been last year actually not
positive but i remember that
pretty pretty distinctly well this level
has nothing oh there we go
feeling good about it oh that guy's got
a chain gun man i'm just gonna run away
from him
you might wanna i'm a coward
yeah i'm gonna have to aim down yeah
you're gonna have to aim down and kill
those
those buffoons nope didn't say rewind it
i know it's okay
uh this game is out so it's on xbox 360
and xbox one
um i'm not sure how much it is
i can look that up though because i have
a laptop
i know it's okay
you'll save them
eventually
oh they both died still
14.99
the backs always got her back the
production yeah
are you still trying to save everyone
i'm trying
it's so hard to save people you save two
of them right
okay you got two people now i think so
when you charge up
it does the charge up of the last person
whoever you save i don't know
is
oh purple stuff apparently it's gonna
explode
good call i know a lot about
exploding cams floating canisters
the question is can you reflect the
chain gun guys
i tried to do that thing where i jump on
their heads yeah it didn't work
only with uh
zackasaurus oh you you can chop
downwards i don't know where that would
take you though
they're making me waste my precious
time
ain't nobody got time to waste on
dynamite guys oh look at that
oh real it's okay
okay rewind
and then play it safe
this guy can only chomp and uh
there you go
where did the arrow say did you see the
finger
telling you
oh that was risky maneuver there's a
clock back there too i need that clock
maybe a little rewind
to rethink your decisions
i'm going
going back in time oh yeah no we we
definitely need zackasaurus powered up
see that yeah that's how he didn't get
the clock oh he's gonna get the clock
right no you should yeah damn it
you're the one that tells me these
things it's true but when you're yeah
when you're playing it's harder to mid
play you just want to keep jumping
yeah skate it out
oh yeah
i like the spam there the spam insured
it so now you can technically not ever
go down there yeah exactly so we're
starting to
figure it out
i think i'm still a little late yeah
exactly all right i agree
oh what is that guy
mad maxian oh no no no
i tried to um to reverse before i died
but it didn't
okay so i'll hit him from the other end
oh wait i should've you know what i
could do
is die not not die
did i do a barrel but what i was going
to say was i could kill that barrel
before it hits me
maybe perhaps and then save my dino
okay so
timing wasn't there thought process was
great yeah i had i had con
no they all they exploded once that
happened
unfortunate oh you saved one of them
okay good it's all
you need to do the uh oh god seven
seconds there's i don't know if there's
enough time i think you're gonna be able
to get
they gotta give throw you a bone and
give you
or we gotta cheese it we gotta find a
way to cheese it how do you cheese it i
don't know we keep cloning yourself
but i guess you can't because there's
like
multiple stages to this boss like an ad
phase and a clause phase personally i
would think that would be a flaw
if you
got the blossom run out of time if you
can't beat the boss because you don't
have enough time well we already saw
that happen though earlier
so now you have two power-ups you have
gotcha
i killed myself twice in a row doing the
exact same thing
because i haven't learned [ __ ]
it's okay
you sounded well as a coach
you know coaching it up
uh the reviews up for this game i
believe i think carolyn gave it an eight
it's done
well carolyn liked it
she thought it was it was the kind of
thing where like there's a lot of
humor throughout the game
and they do a really good job of
jesus christ it's not easy to talk and
play at the same time so not during a
boss fight yeah but anyway they do a
really good job of
making the game really entertaining from
the get-go like the whole game is
incredibly
entertaining yeah i mean there's already
been a couple of nostalgia points for
both of us and it has we've only seen
like a couple levels so
okay that was good that was good i liked
what i saw i actually don't know what
i'm doing i don't know it looked good
you killed the ad so now you just got to
keep reversing time
i guess yeah but
yeah i still don't know if you have
enough time
left here for the in terms of the boss
like look how much
how much life he has
life he has left
i [ __ ] died
am i right guys
time traveling [ __ ]
you know it's yeah you know what's bad
too is like you ran out of ranged
characters
i'm gonna retry it do it we got 10
minutes so it's time it's time for you
to shine i can do this i think favorite
year i gotta
i really gotta rush
through this a little bit i think yeah
see ya mad max
it's good knowing you i'm gonna do a
little bit more
speed running yeah i think i think the
whole tip of telling you to kill
everything is not a good tip yeah i
think it's a lie i think you need to
kill stuff go on but
uh
like the right like kill what you need
to and then just get by
nice didn't save him that's okay
leo is kind of like whatevs you know
not a good not a good situation pincered
goob says this is like the toe jam in
earl stream all over again
i was good at toe jamming earl how dare
you
i'm gonna honestly say i think i'm
the best at the dinosaur
yeah
zack source you know why because you can
actually jump on people with this it
just has a massive um hitbox hitbox and
so like
anything that's in my way
except for dynamite oh you can eat the
dynamite though apparently or like
destroy it
how are you going to save him charge it
up charge it up
you can save him if you can kill the
dynamite guy because that's
well your best character is uh dead now
well
until you save them right every
character i've done is dead so let's
oh you got the slow time
no it's not good it's not gonna save me
you know what really sucks is i can
actually i can see that i'm going to die
and i don't
do anything about it that's when you got
to do the time the time time out
oh you can save that person
i think if you let that go it's like a
big
like shotgun effect i think it is too
dino oh that guy didn't do anything
the guy actually was there to die oh the
dynamite guy
okay save yeah there you go
oh nice
there's a clock up there
now you want to go back in time right
uh to wait before i before i did that
yeah so that you can let that your clone
get the clock right go blocky blockerson
hustle
hustle it
don't even bother killing that guy we
don't need that slow time no there you
go now we have 30 seconds for this boss
okay
oh you're maximizing huh you're wearing
max all the time screwing around oh does
that work because we should have been
doing that the whole time
oh [ __ ] oh you know what okay so you
shot him twice right you should just
rewind and let him shoot it again
as ducky used to say
she was on
then you just do that again right
yeah like 10 times higher
do you think do you think you can just
keep doing that and kill the boss before
he even calls his buddies
hypothetically yes right hypothetically
does that make
is that like a flaw
i don't know i mean like i feel like
it's it's almost like a hack-and-slash
kind of mentality you know find a way
because it only seems fair that i can do
this
yeah clone yourself over and over
all right guys so if you want to cheese
your way through bosses this is this is
probably the way
now what i am curious though if this is
intended because i've never like i think
when the copy guys got cappy guys came
for the lobby that one time he was
mix-mashing his guys he never really
duplicated the same guy but this totally
looks like a sound method he didn't
really think his game
i don't know i assume it was intended
obviously they did extensive play
testing on this
you know like it seems ridiculous that
they wouldn't have considered that this
option so it sounds to me like
this is insane
they knew that you could do this and
and now i'm going to do it
this guy's gonna
totally get toasted one more you think
one more guy oh wow
ain't no thing
wow
slow-mo
are you gonna watch the replay of that i
don't know if i want to i feel you might
hurt me like in my heart in your heart
i'll just watch all my mistakes i mean
it's
it's incredibly brutal as a game
watch me die
i'll watch a little bit of it go blocky
i love blocky go blocky
so this is cool it doesn't show my desks
it shows my victorious run as if it were
i never reverse time yeah which is kind
of cool way to
to do this oh look at that massive
hitbox the dyno is clearly one of the
better characters not just in terms of
like how much damage he does but he
really genuinely does look cool
and
i personally like to play as only the
coolest of the cool oh really
if you're going to play anybody i would
place a
skateboarding dinosaur
very close fair enough so i split the
two here one of me goes up there the
other one goes this way
these are like the things that you learn
maybe like the second round of the map
and then this is really good and then i
turn into 80 people
right yep 80 likes that's what you know
yeah
there's like
four there's gotta be like nine of me
there
same thing
good strategy so i probably beat that
level without reversing time and what
like
it was like few minutes it was 60 i
think the clock overall was 60 seconds
yeah so it's like you can beat these
levels in 60 seconds but you're
i mean there's definitely more strategy
than what we've showed off but i think
we started learning i think you started
to adapt and evolve yeah
i've i love what i see so far i'm
incredibly i'm
impressed with this game and i
i definitely want to play more of it i'm
gonna play the dino nice
oh no i died i did a bad job
i'm gonna give you one more death and
then uh i think that's the finito i got
the finito from bonito
so
oh it's okay you're still good
i lost my dino
your best character
oh nice you you blew up the propane
tanks yeah
i still don't know what those are those
oh okay that makes sense actually
they're robots flying in how am i gonna
save him i don't think i can i don't
think you can cause i'm
okay i'll i'll let you try
and then i'll be there then i'll be the
jerk of
can't have a stream without the merry
squeal
blocky
do something
i think you actually hurt them when you
run into them good yeah
all right anyways guys thank you for
tuning in mary's gonna keep playing a
little lots of fun
i definitely
recommend it yep i think it's totally
worth picking up this is really fun
super time for us xbox 360 xbox one 15
14.99 probably if i could go back in
time i would still do this stream great
i like that see that's why you're here
and i just read the questions
anyways guys uh tune in tomorrow for uh
now playing i think titanfall dlc more
titanfall you know time falls out
tomorrow um but yeah thanks
say bye mary oh thank you it was lots of
fun i mean let me go back in time and
redo this ending
okay
thank you it was lots of fun